Are you familiar with Nichzche's idea of
resenting man the slave and master
morality?
>> No. Tell me.
>> So Nichze basically believed and I agree
with him that
pe like we we'll apply it to modern day
context. Poor and middle class people
not all of them but some of them they
seem to be obsessed with the concept of
morality and virtue. And it's not that
morality or virtue are bad but they
weren't able to get external success.
They weren't able to get money. they
weren't able to get the good wife,
whatever, the the nice house. So they
don't really have the life that they
want. And so what they do is they move
the goalpost from external success to
internal virtue, which they conveniently
get to define.
>> So now I don't have to win in life.
Instead, what I can do is I can just
say, "Oh, but I'm a good person." Who
defines what a good person is? You,
because it's subjective to you. So it's
almost like a free copout. I'm not
saying by any means that you shouldn't
want to be a good person or that virtue
and character aren't I feel like my
dad's going to listen to this and he's
going to be like, "Oh my gosh, yeah,
what are you saying?" Like,
>> shout out shout out Jet's dad, dude.
>> Yeah, shout out shout out my dad. But
>> you have to understand that like people
are constantly coping. It's
subconscious. It's they're not even
aware of it. And then I for me, I just
can't stand these people because they're
so obsessed with morality and virtue and
they're like, "Oh, I hate all these
people." when it's like I don't think
you're aware that what you're doing is
just code because you couldn't get the
external success. I'm not saying
external success is everything in life,
right? There's nuance to this of course,
but Nietze recognized this. He realized
that it's like, hey, these people,
they're kind of just making up some
[__] to make themselves feel better.
And that's what happens. And I mean, I'm
a Christian myself, but a lot of
Christians do this where they're like,
"Oh, you know, people online say that
Jesus is the personification of slave
morality." you know the the person they
have resentment built up against the
people that are successful then they
switch they they get to choose what's
actually right but the thing is is that
>> Jesus is not slave morality at all
because slave morality comes from a
place of resentment and Jesus didn't
have resentment so I really hate that
narrative online but it's like you'll
you I will admit that you see this a lot
in Christian communities or whatever
where they'll kind of be like h like you
know it's it's harder for surely I tell
you that it's harder to get into the
kingdom of heaven than for a camel to
walk through a needle, whatever that
Bible verse is. And they're like, you
shouldn't get money. Like, that's
anti-Christian. And it's like, well, you
could do amazing things with money. You
can help people with money. It's not
inherently. Yeah. It's cope. It's cope.
Hope.
>> So, the problem is you go online, you
say that you are, it's funny because I
I've posted a few videos on this over
the over my time on social media and
every time I get stitched a hundred
times, everyone's like, you know, [__]
this guy, Jeff.
>> Out of touch.
>> Yeah. And it's funny because they'll be
like, you know, you'll get a comment. He
actually thought we were going to agree
with him. No, I I didn't think you were
going to agree with me. I was just
willing to say what needed to be said.
But these people are it's just
everywhere you go, you see coco cope. I
used to be that guy. That's how I know.
Right. And I'm not saying everyone does
this. I'm not saying everyone that is
concerned about being a good person is
doing it out of resentment for people
that have external success. I'm not
saying that at all. But a very large
percentage of them surely are.
>> It's such a cheap shot as well. Like
it's so predictable. Before you look at
the comment section, you can already see
like this is out of touch. He doesn't
understand. He thinks that the only
thing that matters is materialism. And
yeah, there's this idea idea from Isaiah
Berlin called the inner citadel.
Familiar with that? Very similar to what
you're talking about. So he says um when
the path to human fulfillment is
blocked, we retreat into ourselves into
a kind of inner citadel where we're
walled off against all of the fearful
ills of the world and we make our own
laws. So an example of this would be um
your leg gets injured in a battle and
you have the choice to either try and
rehabilitate the leg but if you can't
rehabilitate the leg then you cut your
leg off and denounce that the desire for
legs is misguided and must be subdued.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Like this we see it
everywhere. People that say weight has
no bearing on health because they've
struggled to lose weight. People who say
that jobs are for suckers because
they've struggled to hold one down and
they turn to a life of crime. people who
have been uh cheated on and found it
difficult to get a relationship to work.
So they turn to polyamory or they become
incelss like at each of these different
I guess it would be vols uh at each of
these different junctures what somebody
is doing is saying the world's denied me
that which I want. I'm going to rewrite
the rules retreat into myself so that I
no longer need to face the reality that
I could get it if I did something
different. And again, like this is
there's two very very unpopular things
to talk about online. There's many, but
like two that are kind of reliable
philosophically. One of them is that and
the other is the arrival fallacy. If you
say the view from the top of the
mountain that you're climbing up is not
going to be as satisfying as you think
it is.
>> You sound like a fat guy at a buffet
telling someone who's starving that food
doesn't taste that good. Yeah. Like you
suck the engine out of them and the
oxygen gets pulled out of the room. It
it's seen as uh like a bourgeoa. It's
seen as judgmental, as opulent. And
rightly so. You, a person who has the
thing that I want, are telling me, a
person who doesn't have that thing and
wants it, that the thing I want won't
satisfy me. But how many people that
have got a problem with their self-worth
or a scarcity mindset
reach some level of success or fame or
monetary notoriety and then go man
>> all my inner problems were solved. It
was so great. Like so one of two things
is happening with that which is the
first one. It is true that when you
achieve something that you try to fill
an internal void with an external
success, it's not going to reliably
work.
>> Yeah.
>> The other one is that everybody that
reaches a level of success is part of
some weird cult cabal that's all
cartelling to convince other people to
like pull the ladder up after them so
that they It's like
>> no one else can win.
>> Exactly. Exactly. It's like, "Oh, it's
not that good. I'm [__] idiots."
Like, no, that's obviously not the case.
It's obviously the case that people
can't fill internal voids with external
accolades.
>> Yeah, most people don't realize how much
being dehydrated impacts their
performance, which is why for the last 5
years, I've started pretty much every
morning with Element. Element is a tasty
electrolyte drink mix with everything
that you need and nothing that you
don't. This orange salt in a cold glass
of water is like a sweet, salty, orangey
nectar, and I really tell the difference
when I take it versus when I don't. It
plays a critical role in reducing muscle
cramps and fatigue. Helps to optimize
brain health and regulate your appetite
while also curbing cravings. Best of
all, they have a no questions asked
refund policy with an unlimited
duration. So, you can buy it and try it
for as long as you want. And if you
don't like it for any reason, they'll
just give you your money back. Plus,
they offer free shipping in the US.
Right now, you can get a free sample
pack of Element's most popular flavors
with your first purchase by going to the
link in the description below or heading
to drinklnt.com/modernwisdom.
That's drinklnt.com/mottomwisdom.
Congratulations, you made it to the end
of a clip and the full length episode is
available right here.
Come on.